alexandria ocasio-cortez telling
americans not to believe the crime they
see in their cities every single day aoc
coming under fire for downplaying the
massive looting sprees plaguing the
country after saying quote a lot of
these allegations of organized retail
theft are not actually panning out i
believe it's a walgreens in california
cited it but the data didn't back it up
that's in spite of the new videos that
seem to come out every day showing more
and more brazen lawlessness and local
officials keep blasting the liberal
policies that enable the crimes to
happen in the first place
undoubtedly
bad law and bad policy is driving this
most recent
spike in crime that we're seeing in los
angeles if you look at the types of
crimes that are concerning us right now
they are directly rooted in
bad law from the legislature and bad
policy from l.a county district attorney
george gascon
so greg here we are with another
strategy of telling people what they're
experiencing or seeing in their
neighborhoods or the videos that they're
seeing directly isn't happening
that's why i mean it's funny when i
listen to aoc
i don't or any politician or any
activist or
i'm not upset at the criminals because
they're just reacting to the incentives
criminals criminalize
it's those it's aoc it's the it's the
leftist da's the far left activists who
provide the incentives no bail a no cash
bail is one of them but i'm also
you know
this caused me to go back and read this
the some of the stuff that's out about
the smash and grab there's also we got
to lay a lot of blame on the virtue
signaling companies
who when this crap went down
said that they were supporting the
activists and that property destruction
wasn't violence mark jacobs excused the
looting in my neighborhood he had a
store there my
neighborhood got destroyed millions of
dollars in damages people laughed about
it on the set um
and he said the damage isn't violence
and it was easy to say that when you
were super rich you owned the stores and
you were insured meanwhile your entire
neighborhood's gone so the new york
times had an interesting piece where
they linked today's heinous crimes to
the to the evolution of this criminality
during the floyd and kenosha riots so
you have professional thieves groups
gangs exploiting the media's
redefinition of riots as protest right
we talked about that they exploited law
enforcement simultaneously as they were
stretched thin trying to deal with the
protests but also being demoralized and
being filmed in case they ever did try
to stop you know any kind of crime so
this never was about protest this was
about profit uh
even the stores that were victimized
they didn't want to discuss it so the
democrats have strayed so far from a
sensible world view
when you can't see that no cash bail and
these leftist da's are incentivizing
more crime you're not fit to run
anything aoc i've always defended her i
thought she's got charisma and charm and
and but to say something to that to
people that have actually experienced it
she's no good she's a bad person you
know richard corporations in california
not to mention small businesses are
closing dozens of stores and might not
hurt the corporation much but it sure
hurts hurts the people who work at those
stores who need to earn a living i'll
never forget there was a video interview
of a woman named stephanie disabled in
minneapolis last summer who was
interviewed not a white woman and she
was crying because the stores that she
was able to walk to that she could be on
her own and be self-sufficient with were
destroyed and nobody cared about it well
listen i think there's no there's nobody
that wants looting in their community
right nobody wants looting nobody wants
crime in their community and i think
when you have and i think it's very
important that democrats in this moment
as we see an increase in crime don't
play lip service to it and say here are
here's how we're actually going to
address that crime here's what we know
we know there's certain cases in which
cash no having cash bill works in some
cases where it doesn't work when you
have crimes of desperation when people
go into grocery stores and steal baby
formula that is a crime of desperation
that should be met with cash bail when
you have somebody with a rap sheet
that's as long as the pair of pants that
i have on right now right you those
people aren't aren't supposed to get
cash bail those people that we should
find a way to say listen you will get
punished or we'll give you incentives
incentives also do work remember the
first step back was all about providing
in sense of those folks who made
mistakes and are trying to correct their
lives so we have to have a delineation
between those two things so jesse but
democrats built the crime wave and now
they don't want to pay lip service to
what's happening and actually deal with
it when the policies they voted for and
put in place are still justifying today
including the governor of california now
it's like oh sorry i guess we'll try and
clean this up well that's why i'd rather
have a dumb politician than a stubborn
politician because they're both going to
make the same mistake but the dumb
politician will change their mind
stubborn politicians just keep doing the
wrong thing like the democrats do over
and over again the left is struggling
with the politics of smash and grab just
the same way they struggled with the
politics of the black lives matter riots
because it's on tape katie
you can't say to the american people
it's not happening when it's happening
and you're seeing it on local tv every
day at five or six you're seeing it on
facebook seeing it on cable news you
can't say it's not happening remember
antifa is this doesn't exist jared
nadler said what was the mayor from
chopper chaz it's the summer of love
until there's a couple homicides cnn is
a mostly peaceful protest so they have
to make a decision are they going to own
up and address some of these stupid
policies or they're going to deny and
deflect the difference is this time as
opposed to the summer of 2020 there's no
righteous racial component to the riots
these are professional
criminals doing targeted heists is that
about trump it's about george floyd it's
about burglary yeah and you can't say to
someone in a commercial shopping
district downtown with security cameras
everywhere and 100 witnesses is about
george floyd you can't deny it when it's
happening in the dark you know in the
inner city someone gets shot no security
cameras two gang members you can
you can deny that you can't deny it if
you see it in your own eyes well you
can't deny it dana if it happens to you
and you've interviewed a lot of people
on newsroom who are victims of these
policies well and also if it were people
smashing and grabbing baby food then
maybe you know that would be one thing
but this is not jean valjean okay
they're like going into nordstrom or
louis vuitton or any of these other
fancy stores and smashing the windows
scaring the employees
running the customers out of town and we
talked to this woman today her name is
rachel michelin she's a california
retail association she said to aoc it
absolutely is happening and
one of the problems that she sees is
that imagine that you have a big box
store like a nordstrom and then small
businesses will try to get as close as
they can to that nordstrom so that they
can be within walking distance or get
that foot traffic and if nobody's going
to the stores then it doesn't maybe
nordstrom can afford it though they
shouldn't have to but the small business
owners they're the ones who can't do it
the last thing i would say is we really
have to focus on this and i want to do a
story on it soon
this idea that you can one of the
reasons are getting all of this fancy
material luxury goods is because there's
no policing of the resale on the
internet so you can go you can make up
your own like amazon store or on
ebay and then you're selling these fancy
bags for less expensive price and they
you actually can track the merchandise
but there's no one policing any of this
resale and that's a big problem i can go
on there and get like let's say a nice
bag cheaper and you won't get in trouble
and they won't get in trouble
and they don't get prosecuted and they
don't get better maybe maybe we're going
a little too fast again against these
smash and grab people
right but if you say anything mean about
fauci they'll take you right off the
internet
craig still has christmas shopping to do
yes he's on a budget i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now